bonsoir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs ce soir
deux invités tout d'abord le champion du
portugal junior 892 josé de sousa oui
bon show bonsoir pitot et oui on
continue d'importer donc en profiter
puisque là les portugais peuvent nous
écouter c'est vrai bono et et notre
questar habituel nicolas magic giffard
bon c'est comme ça
or nicolas dans ton actualité c'est
ainsi c'est il ya un nouveau livre qui
vient de sortir aux éditions normal
alors on va en parler un petit peu c'est
à cette fois c'est un livre non plus sur
l'histoire des champions et et les
grands tournois mais pour les débutants
pourront apprendre à jouer aux échecs
sans exercice pour progresser aux échecs
chez bornman par nicolas giffard et
jacques et le biais là je le montre à
l'écran
nicolas tu peux nous parler un peu de ce
ce livre du principe de se dire ok mais
peu particulier c'est un livre qui est
conçu pour l'interactivité maximum entre
le lecteur et le contenu
le lecteur a donc sans exercice à
résoudre et voyez donc comme si chaque
page montre chaque page comporte deux
exercices chaque exercice à sa solution
sur la page suivante donc invisibles
parce que tous les exercices sur les
pages de droite
les solutions sont sur les pages de
gauche qu'on ne peut voir donc qu'en
retournant la page on n'a donc pas aller
au bout du livre pour avoir la solution
est dans chaque solution on explique à
un principe du jeu ça une petite morale
disons à chaque exercice
et voilà c'est en même temps un livre
pour chercher et pour apprendre
voilà donc ces listes retrait progressif
puisque les problèmes vont du plus
simple
oui c'est à dire disons qu'on l'a fait
pour mettre les questions concernant les
ouvertures au début du livre celle
concernant le milieu de partie tactique
et stratégie sont un peu séparés au
milieu du livre donc et puis à la fin du
livre
les exercices concernant les finales
alors avec un principe quand on trouve
aussi une colada et
dans les magazines dans l'élite dans les
journaux qui parlent d'échec qui
essaient d'évaluer un petit peu le
niveau
oui de lecteurs donc là ce livre
s'adresse aux joueurs classés entre
débutants complets et 1600 points hauts
comme tu les spectateurs on a conçu des
points distribués en fonction de la
résolution des exercices de cette
manière que celui qui trouve tout un
1600 lots alors bien sûr c'est un peu
aléatoire c'est un peu approximatif
comme jugement de deux niveaux
mais bon voilà l'idée c'était ça c'est
si on résout 100% des problèmes on à
1600 points elo le prochain livre est
prévue pour faire une barre à 1800 et le
troisième à 2000
l'aardonyx qui devient un niveau
international c'est la limite des
classements internationaux et on
essaiera de faire des exemples plus dû
retirer un peu aussi bien pour jacques
et le bdia que pour moi même de nous
notre expérience de joueur donc voilà
nicolas giffard est inquiet biya sorte
un nouveau livre aux éditions borneman
sans exercice pour progresser je leur
montre encore la caméra donc disponible
dans toutes les bonnes librairies
voilà bien un petit commentaire je pense
que pour progresser il ya vraiment que
la recherche justement des exercices
comme ça pour progresser c'est ce
cagnois faussé par la recherche qu'on
progresse voilà ce que je disais aussi
nicolas l'émission c'est que ce livre
sur le concept ressemble un petit peu
oui
alléché moby fischer en fait il a fait
deux livres donc mais 62 meilleur parti
et avant les faits un livre pour
l'initiation jeu et ça le principe dix
on était un peu pareil
un peu moins avec moins fournie avec la
proximité des solutions moi j'avais le
souvenir pour faire ce livre ce qui m'a
donné l'idée c'est le livre de ian d'sa
hors jeu pas si j'osais je relève et le
maire trepel le meilleur coût en
allemand et en anglais on peut le
trouver mais malheureusement pas en
français et qui avait donc ce principe
d'un exercice avec sa solution derrière
cachés et qu'on peut voir en retournant
simplement la page et c'est un livre
très très puissant pédagogiquement parce
que les deux grands maîtres aussi bien
en deçà york
dans les exemples de leurs propres
pratiques et fille était très
péremptoire dans la solution disait il
faut jouer s'il faisait ça pouvait
évidemment être contestable mais le
grand maître affirmé ça et comme il
avait joué
même la partie il avait analysé
longtemps je crois qu'on peut leur faire
confiance d'ailleurs j'avais décelé très
très peu d'erreurs même maintenant avec
l'informatique dans leur analyse on voit
peu d'erreurs aussi un des meilleurs
entraîneurs du monde qui est de vos
rides ce qu'ils appliquent cette méthode
puisque chaque fois il donne aux
exercices comme ça
très souvent donc voilà donc ça aurait
été très bien sans exercice pour
progresser aux échecs
voilà de mycologie fort encore un
best-seller à venir ça n'arrête pas
nicolas au prix modique de 79 francs
libre aux jo alors l'actualité cette
semaine on va y venir c'est avant tout
le championnat du monde junior qui se
déroule donc à erevan en arménie avant
de commencer à parler de ce champion du
monde on va revenir sur les sujets qu'on
avait abordé la semaine dernière donc
les émissions de diagonale sont toujours
disponibles en différé vous pourrez y
revenir vous donc sur l'émission de la
semaine dernière on va continuer avec
donc cette semaine notre interview de
l'inauguration au jardin du luxembourg à
paris un espace et chicken beaucoup de
personnalités étaient présentes dont la
championne de france 1999 christine flir
bonjour toujours dans le jardin c'est là
cette fois avec christine finir champion
de france 99 bonjour festive bonjour à
et loire alors tu habites à montpellier
tu es champion de france et tu viens à
paris alors pourquoi pourquoi venir au
sénat est ce que tu t'es content d'être
là et pourquoi es tu venu mais d'abord
parce que j'ai été invité à manger avec
le président donc monsieur poncelet et
c'était une très belle occasion pour moi
de venir à paris l'inaugurer ce jardin
du luxembourg
c'est échiquier pendant super donc une
ambassadrice du jeu d'échecs en fait
maintenant un peu ça ouais j'ai partie
de la vieille dame est ton actualité
apprécions que la france tu veux jouer
des tournois tu vas partir un peu
partout non je vais m'occuper de mes
débuts mais des enfants d'abord un petit
peu et puis ensuite j'irai jouer le
championnat d'europe en géorgie au mois
de novembre
d'accord donc très bonne actualité merci
christine voilà donc la championne de
france christine fier champion de france
donc on revient à ce
ce championnat du monde junior donc en
arménie beaucoup de monde et on a
discuté un petit peu avant nicolas josé
ne très très fort joueur
ah oui championnats du monde juniors
très relevé comme tous les ans en fait
de très fort joueur on note l'absence
seulement deux peut-être ponomariov
bacrot qui sont plus jeunes mais qui
rappelle plus participé dont on aurait
aimé les voir se confronter à un bond à
ses joueurs qui sont quand même très
fort il le champion c'est galkin - russe
le sol russe du tournoi si je suis dit
un ami et puis gagne le ton - donc il
est très fort donc les rues s'arrête pas
de nicolas de sortir newey
apparemment il était en tête tout le
tournoi il était détaché auprès trois
quatre ans mais il a toujours gardé la
tête et la dernière ronde il a battu
casting josh voilà il termine donc il
leur lègue aux cinquième sixième place
kassim janov que gbagbo est rabattue et
las vegas
oui oui oui un premier temps et quelque
2600 au point donc
depuis qu'il s'entraîne donc c'est ça
montre le niveau comme du temps j'ignore
si moins de 20 ans moins de 20 ans mais
au fait des joueurs mais et c'est encore
plus jeunes peuvent quand même
participer au tournoi bien sûr et donc
de ses 20 ans alors parmi tous ces
joueurs de l'ess parce que beaucoup de
joueurs de l'ess dans les premières
places
on va en trouver quand même et on a même
un français qui était l'avant qui a très
bien figuré
oui c'est 6 rue marcellin de là alors je
dirais c'est plus la nouvelle génération
c'est la renouvelle c'est encore plus
viennent coiffer la série de marcelin il
a 20 ans je crois juste ça peut pas il
doit être limite de la catégorie et il a
joué apparemment tout le tournoi aux
alentours de la table numéro 10 donc il
n'a jamais lâché
groupe pas tout à fait de tête mais
juste un peu derrière il a fait un très
beau ton à mon avis doit faire une
performance à plus de 2500 oui j'ai
d'ailleurs parce que chercheur qui perd
qu'une partie sur donc sur royal outré
seconde c'était très long
c'est très sombre et il a perdu lancé
vous de shkin justement qui finit d'un
5/8 dans les toutes dernières secondes
donc ça veut dire que bon s'il avait
battu il était pour les toutes premières
places
malheureusement ces moules frites un
très fort joueur aussi donc
alors donc très très jolie tourments de
serre est une marionnette c'est pourquoi
cette semaine nous allons étudier nous
c'est parti et la semaine prochaine
invité exceptionnel diagonale justement
cyril marcellin donc sur emerson la
semaine prochaine viendra analyser son
propre championnat du monde junior sur
diagonale donc en attendant on va
étudier enfin va regarder et tu dis est
un drame parce que on n'aura pas le
temps de tout voir évidemment mais on va
regarder une jolie partie de cyril
barcelone lors de ce championnat du
monde donc je vous rappelle que pour
suivre la partie avec nous vous la voyez
évidemment sur la vidéo vous avez deux
autres possibilités vous allez sur la
planète jarrah en cliquant sur le bouton
de jouer à votre droite qui vous donne
une page vous pouvez suivre la partie et
autres possibilités vous pouvez aussi
charger le fichier de la partie le
fichier pgn comme c'est indiqué sur le
bouton et elle est visible grâce à des
programmes téléchargeables dans la
partie différée de diagonale voilà les
explications sont données à ce niveau là
donc on va démarrer la vision de cette
de cette partie donc que cyril martiaux
neil qui a donc les blancs on va
remettre la partie au début puisqu'elle
était déjà un peu avancé donc si le
marseillais josé que tu que tu connais
un peu parce qu'il est de paris et je
connais un peu même
c'est marrant parce que je vous dis
était très jeune il voulait des
professionnels et il voulait travailler
les échecs et toujours beaucoup
travaillé les échecs et il aime ça et je
me souviens qu'il était donc 2200 et
commencer juste avec l'as international
ai et voulais déjà être professionnel et
très fort joueur participe au
championnat du monde était très
ambitieux donc ça fait plaisir de voir
finalement à ce niveau alors on va voir
les premiers coups de 7,2 cette partie
donc 6 rue marcellin qui démarre avec
des pièces donc blanche avec le coup
encore une fois les poux classiques au
centre on en a déjà parlé aux échecs ont
essayé au début souvent de dominer le
centre de contrôle et les quatre
centrales
je veux dire aussi dire que oui nicolas
connais très bien aussi syrie puisqu'il
faut dans le même club
on a joué qu'eux mêmes d'accord on a
joué un grand rôle de robin a quitté
danse il ya deux ans pour le mans le
mans s'arrête ne fait plus de l'équipe
en nationale 1 alors donc cyril
marcellin va jouer maintenant à meaux
l'équipe de maubeuge d'accord donc ça
s'est produit que l'agresseur dans
l'histoire d'un club français donc
l'adversaire répond avec un coup on en
symétrique qui va engager la partie sur
des ouvertures qu'on appelle mondial
nicolas oui c'est un coût qui ne vaut qu
pas directement le centre qui contrôle
la case aux 5
donc cette case ici que j'étais un mec
qui se retendent un peu freiné
l'expansion des blancs mais sans plus
on va passer les premiers coups donc le
coup deux des quatre ensuite les noirs
répondre par le cavalier sur la case f6
coûts de développement logique qui
attaquent le pion qui attaquent le pion
développement des blancs en même temps
que de protection du plomb les pions
centrale toujours un développement
finalement qui contrôle les cases les
caisses centrales le cadre des cadets 5e
5 donc encore en cours enfants nicolas
le premier coup d si c'était un courant
pas on était encore un petit peu petit
coup de pions qui n'a pas l'air très
agressif oui ces marins qui est apparu
qu'à devenir un mode d'une dizaine
d'années et puis qui est retombé un peu
dans les oublie
parce que elle a subi quelques défaites
assez cinglante s'appelle la défense
tchèque
si les noirs continuent ensuite en
sortant la dame qui est assez libéré sur
la case à 5
c'est une idée assez bizarroïde mais qui
a été à la mode pendant il ya une
dizaine d'années je sais pas si je ne
connais pas cette partie donc je ne sais
pas si ça a été ça la continuation
alors on va voir donc si remercier
choisi le début aussi relativement
prudent ce pas un coût non plus très
agressif
non c'est pas le plus c'est le coup j'ai
dit oh ouais mais c'est un coût qui a la
réputation d'être anglais les noirs
disons de noisettes ou fait de les
étouffer petit à petit le coup g2 g3 qui
préfigure le développement du fond blanc
chose est sûre la casse g2 ce qu'on
appelle un fou un film qui est ou qui
contrôlerait cette grande diagonale
personnellement j'aime beaucoup ce coup
parce que c'est vrai que la continuation
théorique autre que j'ai 3 cf 4 et l'a
appelée secoue bien sûr on joue des
médecins comme l'apprécient nicolas mais
ce que j'aime bien en fait en mettant le
fou en g2 c'est qu'il donne un contrôle
supplémentaire au plomb et 4 qui on va
le voir peut s'avérer un peu faible sur
un développement notre développement du
fou et d'autre part on ne pourrait
croire que le fou sur cette diagonale
sur la diagonale h18 n'a pas vraiment
d'avenir puisque il ya le plus ans et
cissé en bessette qui finalement le
l'empêchent de voir l'horizon
voilà ce matin ce tournoi sur gazon lors
si si qui vont
qui luttent contre le fou j'essaierai
démontrer que c'est pas si vrai par la
suite aulas alors on va voir
donc les noirs choisi sa de sortir
maintenant leurs cavaliers l'avantagent
de secours nicolas c'est que ça comptera
une nouvelle fois la case de 5 et vous
permettre aux noirs de jouer le coup 7
en 5 pour contre attaquer au centre tôt
ou tard alors oui oui le noir vont
effectivement pousser leurs pions du roi
de 2,15 en 5
c'est la façon presque ludique d'avoir
un contrôle du centre acceptable après
les couleurs et je veux juste préciser
que le problème des noirs le majeur pour
la majeure des noirs c'est qu'ils n'ont
qu'une casse pour développer deux pièces
le fou ces 8es le cavaly b8 parce que
donc si on met le cavalier d'essai pour
forget aux cinq blocs l'horizon du fou
sémite
donc sauf on ne peut pas partir alors
mais si on sort vont donc ou sortir le
fou alors justement si on le sort en
fion kétou donc on va jouer b6 et bâle a
juste le fou qui temps j'ai deux va
commencer à prendre de l'ampleur
voilà donc qu'il faudrait faut éviter
pour une noire d'affaiblir ce côté là
l'art est sous le slogan mais
malheureusement il n'y a pas vraiment
d'autre solution pour développer le fou
c'est pour ça qu'au lieu de cavaye 17
des fois on se fout des quatre mais
c'est ils ont un coût un autre coup qu'à
valider c'est ce dont nous nous
comportons nous en tout cas voilà enfin
qu'on va voir
donc les blancs maintenant jouer un coup
alors qui peut paraître jusqu'où ils
méritent commentaires nicolas
on s'attend à ce que les blancs face au
petit soumettre leurs fous sur la case
g2 une sorte le cavalier et elle joue un
coup qui a l'air de
ne pas s'occuper du centre ne pas
s'occuper de rock n ont plus qu elle
peut être l'idée de se faire une idée
c'est d'empêcher les noirs de pousser
leurs pions b71 b5 b6 l'idée et puis ça
peut éventuellement menacer de pousser
encore une fois ce pion ski et prend
beaucoup d espace donc je pense que les
noirs vont répliquer par a7 a51 vendu
mothron parce que mme énormément on les
bat et blanc pousser plus loin que à 4
ce pion parce que justement un assassin
qui l'empêcherait peut-être des six pour
pour développer le fou enfin kito mais
il faut préciser aussi que l'idée
bessette b5 et très forte parce qu'elle
menace b4 qui qui enlève le cas 24
kathak lecavalier et qui a l'air de la
retrouve dans la réserve et le contrôle
de cette structure 4 qui peut s'avérer
faible comme tu lui sinon tout alain
bessette b5 est un coup utile disons
pour mais il ya beaucoup de joueurs avec
les blocs qui laisse faire ce métier
vous intéresser alors on va voir
donc les noirs ne choisisse choisi de ne
pas répondre mais de contre attaquer au
centre en tout cas fait de se développer
plutôt que de contre attaquer en tout
cas de se développer au centre ce qui
secoue permet tout simplement non
seulement d'avoir une action central de
tarbes notation mais aussi de pouvoir
sortir le fouet fuite ici sur la case de
7 pour permettre le petit rock au noir
alors la place des blancs et rosés
moscou serait ce plutôt une nouvelle
fois qu'il a choisi de jouer cavalier e
2 qui est social alors il effectivement
il a choisi le coup car yoder pourquoi
deux plutôt qu'en ex 3 nicolas sûrement
parce que pour ne pas gêner le fou qui
va s'installer en fientes et voilà le
fond qui va s'installer un g2 a besoin
d'avoir de l'espace pour en vendre
l'action donc le période on ne peut être
moins gênant h3 même bouche-trou parce
que comme l'idée de fous j'ai deux c'est
de justement de contrôler quatre places
et le cavalier devant le fou
contredirait un peu complètement le
développement des bleus donc de cavalia
2 c'est le coût normal
donc au 6e coulée noire répandre
logiquement par la sortie de leur fou de
cases noires qui va leur permettre
ensuite de mettre leurs droits à l'abri
en faisant le petit rock et l'autre idée
aussi c'est bon à prendre
on va voir comment ça des renforts nous
toujours d'un ouverture sur les joueurs
savent à peu près ce qu'il veut le faire
à ce moment de la partie
en général les deux camps ce genre de
position centrale font le petit rock
s'est vite alors 7 pour les blancs fou
j'ai deux logiques on sait exactement le
coût pour pour lequel j'ai trois étés a
été joué maintenant les noirs retarde un
peu le petit rock en mettant la dame sur
la casse et 7
alors pourquoi mettre la main sur cette
case là on peut se poser la question je
pense que ils ont vu que les blancs ont
un plan possible qui est de pousser f2f
4 et à mon avis ce coup de pub destinée
déjà à l'avance à contrôler la case
centrale 5 donc tu encore une
surprotection vous étonnerai 7 4 75 et 5
est protégé par le pion des six par le
client 17 et maintenant la dame se
postent ici ou là une nation au moins
défensive le web et les click ou
prophylactiques pour éviter pour éviter
des problèmes plus tard
donc petit robot pour les blancs
là les noirs choisissent de ne pas faire
le petit rock mais de lancer une attaque
alors là c'est vrai cela tu as ça change
tout c'est complètement imprévue et donc
le joueur noir avait dans l'idée non pas
le jeu normal à partir de cette
ouverture mais une idée d' attaque sans
roque et donc le roi noir a plutôt
l'idée sans doute d'aller faire le grand
roque à gauche ou de rester au centre et
tout de suite il lance une attaque
contre le roi blanc alors c'est un
problème effectivement quand tu le dis
c'est les noirs ne rentrent pas donc si
le roi rester au centre on peut
cette tour au fond ça tout aura 8 ne va
pas jouer mais on sait vraiment ce que
n'a pas joué c'est c'est donc il faut
faire attention à ce problème là quand
on engage ce type d'action
personnellement je pense que c'est un
mauvais coup de jeune mais parce que
j'ai pas l'utilité du coup h5 qui disent
on a paraphé bien la folie sont des
noirs ils peuvent pas grand roque et
parce que les blancs vont tout de suite
lancé une attaque à l dame par afin que
par exemple en plus ils doivent
développer le foot c'est 8 avant de
grands ok donc je pense que c'est c'est
un coup affaiblissant un coup disons de
jeunes en fait oui un compte aussi des
coups d'oeil on traite même ce genre de
coup des attaques de café c'est à dire
que qui ne marche que dans la rigolade
et en partie sérieuse ne marche pas
alors on va en voir ensuite donc la
levée du corps est planté on peut dire
que l'ouverture est terminée noir ont
dévoilé leur plan qui décide d'attaquer
les plans sont assez sereine parce
qu'ils ont repris un développement
relativement sain
donc ils vont évoluer de cordiner
coordonner au mieux leurs forces ce qui
va être le problème des noirs
probablement pas le problème des noirs
ça va être la plan placement du roi qui
est très délicat
la praticité vit dans l'instant qui pour
l'instant se traîne au centre est ce que
finalement c'était blanc qui vont
attaquer très vite le roi noir alors que
parce qu'ils sont mieux développer et
puis un ep de son mieux coordonner 10
alors on va voir avant de continuer
l'analyse cette partie on va continuer
sur le jardin du luxembourg avec une
encore une interview donc s'est déroulé
lors de cette inauguration avec
justement nicolas giffard or donc
toujours au sénat après christine fli on
voit que dès qu'on parle un petit peu
femmes dans le milieu des déchets qui a
les hommes qui arrivent alors on à
nicolas giffard bonjour nicolas bonjour
stéphane belle ambiance ici j'ai
rencontré christine flir je voudrais
vous présenter que c'est le chien s'il
ya encore des gens ne la connaissent pas
une anecdote il ya une bonne quinzaine
d'années on peut dire j'étais à créteil
pour faire une simultanée il ya une
petite fille une gamine avec des tresses
et puis j'ai joué très très vite quand
je passais devant elle et je me suis
fait comme et noir ratatiner voilà
c'était christine flynn et oui on est on
est on n'avait pas championne de france
par hasard et on est aussi avec là
encore le vice-champion de france avant
de rencontrer etienne bacrot le champion
de france dimanche
albert et là on a le vice-champion de
france david marciano ouvrons soir david
de toulouse d'ailleurs de toulouse mais
là par hasard puisque ma petite copine
habite tout près donc je suis passé sans
même savoir qu'il se passait quelque
chose ici et puis c'est elle qui a
découvert un passe temps il ya trois
jours on lui a dit qu'il se passe est un
événement important alors j'en ai
profité
heureux d'être là c'est sympa quand le
jardin je connaissais pas alors c'est un
peu le hasard c'est le côté mystique du
jeu d'échecs comme ça je sais pas si
c'est mystique que ma copine étudier à
paris mais en tout cas c'est vrai que
c'est une coïncidence heureuse que je
sois là en ce moment et puis je trouve
ça agréable de voir tous ces gens on
voit là ici au sénat
décidément la crème des échecs est
présente à vous paris bonjour voilà un
nom pareil donc voilà donc petite
interview on a vu
vice champion de france nicolas willot
david mars et dont la révélation de
besançon là on pensait pas le voir
éliminés notamment loti et c'est lui qui
a provoqué l'élimination de l'hautil
numéro un français répondent oui il
avait déjà quand même titiller aux
championnats de france par équipes en
nationale 1 où il était passé tout près
de la victoire et il a fini par perdre
donc là
je n'ai pas été surpris finalement
puisqu'il travaille énormément il
il est très sérieux et je pense qu'on
sous estime les coûts voilà jusqu'à
présent on l'a vu faire nul contre des
joueurs très très fort bon on a comme ça
que là c'est marc siano comme le joueur
qui fait nul et même contre doit battre
battre le lotier on ne pensait pas
capable donc voilà l'a démontré en tout
cas dans un championnat de france donc
voilà on revient donc à cette partie ou
décor est planté et on va voir le bon
collard action de 6 rue marcellin il a
joué un coup intéressant c'est le court
h2 h3 donc voilà qui empêche la rupture
n'a l'idée c'est de fermer le jeu si les
noirs pousse à nouveau leurs pions qui
viennent de pousser au cou précédent
avec les vélos bloc le jeu par un voile
et noir ont une idée de pousser leurs
pions pour échanger ce pion ici est
libéré l'action de la tour en fait sur
l'heure voire adverse et un jour ce que
moi je lâche 3 les blancs protège la
case g4 et donc sur le coup h 4 quand tu
veux venir le coup de blocage g3 g4
empêcherait les noirs d'un mort toute
action moi j'aime bien ce coup parce
qu'il a deux buts
d'une part il défend parce que bon soit
4 rouges et kate et finalement cet été
blanc qui m'ont attaqué mais en plus il
permet fouet 300 ils permettent faut 3
sans avoir peur de cavaler g4 qui
attaquent le fou ou 3 il faudra donc à
n'ayant pas peur d'un échange
ce fait soit peut-être favorable pour
les pour les pour les noirs puisque mon
le fou quasiment tous vents très beau
nom sur d'ouverture donc c'est un j'aime
bien ce genre de cookies même temps
défendre et attaquer alors on va voir
comment comment ça se déroule maintenant
alors voilà un coup comme on disait tout
à l'heure le carrier et compte utiliser
il avait peu de pièces pleines un peu
d'endroits de développement il y avait
que la casse des scènes vraiment envie
efficace et on voit qu'après il n'y a
pas beaucoup de classe non plus un
hasard que là il se retrouve à essayer
d'aller sur la case et fuite
qu'est qui est pour l'instant par une
caste très très active on voit très bien
en fait que la stratégie des noirs est
un peu compromise parce qu'on est obligé
de jouer des coups comme ça après 12,9
coup dans une c'est pas très typique
disons c'est merveilleux mais bon le
coup qu'on trouvait mystérieux tout à
l'heure de la dame noire ans et 7
on le comprend mieux maintenant qu'on a
vu les intentions des noirs étaient de
de faire le grand roque et donc ce coup
de dague noire et un peu mieux expliquer
maintenant alors il dit aussi de jouer
le coup
donc de jouer la dame noire ans est
maintenant le cavaliere et fuite va
permettre aux fous de cases blanches
sortir et peut-être pas prêt de faire
leurs angles donc je sais pas si c'est
vraiment prémédité disons comme comme
approche ce qu'il a vraiment joué à h5
en essayant les d'avoir quoi est ce qu
il a joué dams et 7h 5 avait des fuites
dans les dons de faire grand roc ou
alors est-ce que c'est finalement au vu
des difficultés qu'ils rencontrent qui
trouve ses coûts à 91 délibéré en ce
qu'il n'ait pas mis en difficulté et
blanc n'ont fait aucune - mais oui on va
voir l'entente non mais on va voir
entendre donc maintenant en syrie
continue son développement avec tous les
coups de dés blancs ont l'air sain c'est
à dire que c'est ils répondent tous à
des objectifs volet-là cycle de
développement de pièces de contrôle du
centre il s'occupe plus du centre que le
fonds des noirs j'étais présent donc des
pièces sont mieux coordonnés dans toutes
les pièces maintenant blanches sont
sortis ils n'ont pas de point de
l'espace le roi a déjà rockets donc les
tours peuvent rentrer en jeu tout moment
c'est le jeu s'ouvre par que les noirs
restent avec le problème du fou un cv
qui n'est toujours pas développer la
tour en a 8 non plus est ce qu'un
magnifique qu'il faut il faut qu'il
trouve aussi une activité sur la case 2
6 mhz sur la case g6 on peut imaginer
que moore pourrait attaquer en métal
carrière g6 et puis c'est de faire une
attaque sur le call sur le côté droit
mais on voit mal où sont les faiblesses
du côté blanc parce qu'il faut s'y
attaquer fms nikon général voilà l'idée
des noirs c'est d'appliquer le roi blanc
et pour ce faire je vois qu'une
manoeuvre actuellement ça serait de
doubler sur la diagonale ses 8 h 3 les
forces pour attaquer ce pion c'est à
dire jouer d'abord poussé 8 en six ou
1,17
puis la dame sur la même diagonale
ensuite pour attaquer deux fois le pion
du rock à côté de roland mais ça semble
assez assez limité comme possibilité d'
attaque
effectivement il ya il semble pas qui
est assez d'ingrédients pour attaquer le
roi blanc avec succès parce que
normalement en fait c'est le gang disons
qui comme tiers regrouper le maximum de
forces qui est les pièces qui me
coordonnées qui est en jaillir endroit
attaqué aux épices endroit et puis est
en position d'attaquer là les noirs
n'ont que non
c'est pour ça que c'est un peu curieux
c'est beau mais orthodoxie ce moment là
alors mon deuxième coulée noire
choisissent de jouer finalement voilà un
coup qu'on avait envisagé tout au tout
début pour sortir ce fou finalement
alors moment je trouve là par contre par
rapport au coût car les fuites qui
avaient l'air de libérer le fou je veux
ce coût de cette v6 sera pas ans a pas
l'air de voilà ça passe d'être très
cohérent puisque le foot mais non sans
faire des deux côtés bon mais il
n'aurait pu jouer dans ce cas là le
compte des sept décide tout de suite
parce que l'on a l'impression que le cas
rien de 17 était mieux placé avec la
fuite mais j'utilise mes cernes est là
c'est vrai qu'il ya une cohérence entre
les alors le gros problème que doivent
affronter les noirs là c'est que il voit
très bien déferler certainement le pion
blanc 2f 2f quatre dans les coûts
prochain donc le pion dans la f4 pour
faire pression sur 133 faire exploser un
peu la position donc ils doivent prévoir
quelque chose contre ça et c'est pas
facile alors voyons maintenant voilà ça
y est c rie nationaux 4/11 coûts et donc
vous verrez sur notre logiciel sur la
place jamal 11e coup des blancs s'il se
décide de faire une explosion du centre
continue nicolas avec ce couac 200 f 4
les pions blancs maintenant sont postés
centralement parlant sur la case de 5
alors il ya effectivement l'idée par
l'idée de prendre cinq peut-être aussi
l'idée de gagner de l'espace à droite
avec la poussée a une nouvelle fois de
ce qu'il a d'être poussés en f5
peut-être qu'il a ces deux possibilités
avec le pion à f/5 notamment il
empêcherait à la fois le fou noir de ses
8 et puis le cavalier fuite de jouer
donc c'est très très fort parce que même
les noirs n'ont pas intérêt à échanger
leur pion central
si les changent leurs pions eux cinq ils
enlèvent toute la fierté de leur jeu
n'est plus là donc ils n'ont et n'auront
plus à montrer que un camp sur trois
rangées
absolument même tout de suite on peut
imaginer que s'assignera reprennent en
des 84 ensuite la personne blanche et
faciliter le 5 serait facilitée
sukhinova n'ont pas encore développé
leurs pièces mais là il ya comme une
menace concrète c'est de prendre le 5
est peut être jouée au dessus de foi et
de jouer d'après d'harceler la dame qui
se refuse à venir en a 5 et d'avoir
peut-être position qui qui venait
derrière surtout que ça libérerait la
puissance du fou j'ai 2 si on arrive à
jouer un jour au 5 parce que maintenant
les noirs ou un fumi la diagonale par
mes six mois il s'avère que par des six
semaines en substance et si ce n'est
plus protégé donc qu'on peut me dise il
est blanc et a poussé le pion 85
après les échanges de cinq traders faute
et se fout de tout de suite se réveiller
et avoir une action dangereuse donc là
concrètement que montrer que si les
blancs menace de prendre ici donc sur la
reprise en 2 5i reprendre l autre
fournée 5
la dame viendra en 5 et après parents
même un coup comme fief 4 ou fou des
quatre permettrait la vence justement de
ces options à 5 ans suite aux 4 5 avec
une pression ils sont ici c'est des
pièces noires qui ont eu beaucoup de
problèmes voilà ce qui forçait le roi
toujours au centre de retour au centre
donc susceptibles de subir des échecs
des tours qui leur fut mannequin qui a
été champion de france est dernière nous
pas annie que dit que le facteur le plus
important échec c'est le roi est donc là
entre les deux rois et il ya
manifestement sud est mal en point
alors voyons donc les noirs choisissent
des scénes ramener une pièce au contrôle
central par le coup cavaliers en russie
ce donc là c'est très provocateur
vraiment c'est prendre en cas d
empêchement finalement l'idée empêche ou
f4
enfin deux variantes comme on a dit en
tout cas mais ils on pare au plus pressé
je pense alors voyons donc si je choisis
maintenant voilà de faire une percée ici
avec le coût des quatre des cinq donc il
fait une double attaque sur le pion c6
et lecavalier 6 et donc il va
probablement faire exploser un peu tout
ça maintenant il peut faire des échanges
en 5 des échanges en c6 donc simplifier
la position
et peut-être pouvoir attaquer le roi qui
est toujours en fête au centre ce coup
là dans la structure avec dans ces
structures là avec b 6 et 6 dé 6,5
contre eux cadre des quatre le coût des
quatre des cinq est un coup à dix ont un
coût typique puisque ils attaquent tout
de suite le pion c6 qui a perdu sa base
qui était l'option b set puisqu'il a
chopé sicile c'est donc affaibli est ce
une réponse standard d4 d5 danser mais
peut-être que nicolas et puis quand en
règle générale quand le roi de
l'adversaire est au centre on a intérêt
à ouvrir le jeu est donc un coup comme
ça si lecavalier en et six feet même si
le cas mais n'était pas en et 6 le coût
des quatre des cinq et un coût standard
dans ce genre de dans ce genre de partie
quoi structure dont tu vois la grèce
soit restructurée
merci non c'est souvent comme on dit
quand c'est typique d'un ce genre de
position pensons à un tour la culture c
ur qu'à la structure de pions exactement
cette structure option ce coup des
quêtes des 5 et acoustique alors voyant
la réaction des noirs c'est une prise en
r4 avec l'idée point mort si les blancs
prennent le cavalier évidemment
reprendre le fou ans le 3 donc là cyril
choisi tout simplement de reprendre le
pion alors il faut prendre du cavalier
avec peut-être l'idée ne pas reprendre
les pions pour que la tour à tour et
maintenant une action d'un quart et demi
surprise personnellement je m'attendais
plutôt à la reprise avec le pion pour
valoriser un peu de ses pions en
effondrant les vers le centre oui c'est
une possibilité effectivement reprendre
avec le pion les blanches garder la
possibilité de faire une percée au
centre parents 4,5 g data tir il a vu
plus loin il a peut-être les cochons et
déjà ses lacs apparemment les noirs en
l'air de pouvoir échanger des cavaliers
va et soulager beaucoup la pression
c'est vrai mais peut-être série est un
joueur assez solide très solide qui aime
pas trop disons le facteur risque et
donc ils préfèrent garder un petit
avantage plutôt que de risquer par pions
point f4 qui bon détérioré un petit peu
un peu la position des mains du roi
blanc mais qu'est ce qu'un jour plus
agressif aurait pris un f4 comme nicolas
farine en faillite le sien il garde
quand même des possibilités d'attaquer
mais sur quoi ça si les noirs ont
échangé je pense qu'ils ont échangé leur
valeur parce que là la position est
encore petit qu'il faut absolument voir
ce qui se passe donc là les noirs choisi
de prendre le cavalier il reprend avec
le flou gym et il reprend avec le fou
syrie en premier le fouet et gardent la
possibilité après ruth de nos jours de
faire ça merci sans soirée
c'est vraiment qu'en fait il ne perd pas
à cette possibilité et puis menace aussi
éventuellement pions prend pions là qui
est très fort parce que la dame noire
peut pas vraiment s'exposer oui alors
c'est à l'idée c'est que si les blancs
prennent en c6 les noirs reprendre une
c6 tout simplement les blancs pourraient
jouer le coup eux quatre ou cinq noms
bien qu' un petit échec qui attaquent la
dame avec le fou avec des possibilités
d'attaqué fait très fort très important
mais franck mellal et noir vont échanger
les pieds ou non alors donc on va voir
au 14e coup donc énorme et choisi voilà
de se développer de transfert là enfin
de sortir ce fou et de le mettre sur une
position défensive
alors faut que je te tennis a tout de
suite voilà une position défensive en 17
où il protège une avant leurs points
faibles avancées 6 oui c'est un coup
plein de sang froid parce que il estime
que les blancs ne menace pas encore de
percée au centre mais je suis en train
de calculer ça m'a l'air quand même très
risqué mais en tout cas c'est vrai que
je dois avouer que les changes de
cavaliers 6 contre le cabba lieu de
favoriser un peu quand même
la défense la défense center fait raison
je pense que là bon ça qu'il joue un peu
avec sang froid mais peut-être que bon
il a fait éviter le pire 6 5 ne
fonctionne pas mais en règle générale le
défenseur a intérêt à échanger les
pièces surtout les pièces des attaques
adverses
hélas il semble si noir et pu le faire
mais c'est encore assez dynamique là
peut-être que les blancs peuvent percer
alors on va voir ce que je choisis de
faire signer mais voilà il sort sur
saddam sur la colonne ici une robe noire
peut pourrait être en danger
on peut noter clément on va en vendre du
problème parce que ils peuvent choisir
de rock et maintenant nicolas mais du
côté gras rock salaires faibles et de
l'autre côté s'est abîmé aux idées leur
côté aussi puisque le pur noir et sortez
les techno différence
il peut être même une cible en fait ce
qu on pourrait être une cible oui la
tacc nouara a dit ah mais sans dire b
elle a commencé par h5 elle s'est
arrêtée là c'est un peu triste
non mais si je continuais cité dorfman
là on dirait que la position du roi et
durablement mauvaise l'abolition du
rasoir c'est à dire qu' il peut pas
rester au centre à et droit s'est
durablement mauvais puisqu'il a quand
même compromis sa structure avec h5 et
elle dame paraît donc laura noir est
vraiment en difficulté
il n'ya durable sadd avantages durables
sur ce lien alors voyons ce qui se passe
maintenant
menouar choisissent quand même de faire
le petit rock c'est l'homme voilà que ce
couac sommes finalement été condamné il
est devenu ridicule
oui parce qu'il aurait mieux valu que ce
pion reste près au prix du roman donc la
cire il continue son action avec un
petit coup curieux maintenant 16e coup
il joue le roi sur la case achat
encore un coup ou prophylactiques en
fait oui mais là c'est curieux parce que
disons que les coûts profit d'actifs que
je pense doit être fait dans une
position où on peut pas améliorer au
fait c'est à dire on attend
tranquillement quand on améliore
tranquillement la position que je veux
dire donc on joue rouach un ouvrage de
d'ailleurs qui peut-être en souhaitant
passer peut-être meilleur mais là les
noirs peuvent améliorer leur position
telle qu'il fallait et celle en blanc
non les noirs pas améliorer la
prévention est donc peut-être qu'il
fallait agir rapidement pour étouffer
tout de suite les noirs point que de
jouer un coup plutôt que de jouer un
coup
d'attentes au fait on aurait imaginé
pour les blancs une centralisation de la
tour de la gauche en d1 - au centre
pourquoi vous faites simplement de
prendre ces six qui est mon avis donne
des pose des problèmes aux eaux noires
parce que surtout on prend ces six
comprend c'est 6 par exemple ou prince
et six pour les mots alors maintenant on
joue cavalier b5 par exemple comme ayant
des cinq attaquants la dame
et lequel options des fils et le pion
des six obligerait les noirs donateurs
fund
s'ils donnent leur faut maintenant on
reprend avec le pion à en b 5
oui hélas il ya beaucoup de faiblesses
il ya pion à 7 qui est sous feu de la
toile là alors c'est comme ça à tak tak
il ya le pion des six donc que ça
donnerait une position assez assez bonne
ou meilleure encore pour les blancs je
pense que ce que ce cours a h1 qui est
qui et prophylactique mais qui c'est pas
le moment fait indiqué je pense pour
jouer profil d'activité fallait jouer
énergique à mon sens
alors on continue cette partie avec la
tour maintenant des noirs at-on droit
qui vient au centre donc donc centrale
sa mémoire se décident de jouer pour le
centre et place la tour devant la dame
blanche est un coup très utile c'est un
coût qui améliore énormément la position
des noirs série fait de pression
directement sur la peau y sont blanches
donc mon avis les noirs ont peut-être
évité le pire en ce moment c'est à dire
peut-être évité le coup de massue
voilà alors maintenant on s'érige où
sont fous sur la case g5
alors c'est là où on voit qui fait
pression en fait sur sa la faiblesse
noire le petit pion aux cinq puisque
c'est le cas et qu'il protège il fait
pression sur les défenseurs en fait et
menaces tout simplement de gagner un
pion de gagner un pion important puisque
c'est un pion qui défendent est un petit
peu laurent devoir donc enfin qui était
censé le faire en tout cas le départ oui
les noirs peuvent pas protéger ce pion
on notera stéphane que s'il joue le coup
qui est une grosse erreur g7 g6 g7 g6
pour protéger le plan h 5
eh bien le cavalier noir serait en prise
par deux pièces blanches protéger une
seule fois il sera donc perdu oui
puisque le fou et la tour ici gagnera
une pièce tout simplement sur le cas des
filles donc on voit mal comment les
noirs pourraient pas protégé maintenant
ce pion alors les noirs choisissent de
jouer le coup une contre attaque avec le
coup d'avancé ville est prévue par
nicolas se sait qui était visé vers mais
moi je trouve ça très bon coup parce que
ça attaque h3 et en même temps sa menace
pétait cavaliers prend des 5
donc mon as peut-être cavaliers prendre
laisse un goût de beaucoup pressés dont
l'époux vélib est là surtout le coup
précédent il attaquait la d'avancé 7
parmi c'est à dire que le cavaly pouvait
reprendre le cavalier attaquant la dame
est
et maintenant les ménages la menace qui
avait dû prendre 5 est forte sur quelle
étrange où pranger 5e puis bon mais un
peu disons de d'animation donc la suite
à un bon coup de défense attaque et
défend même temps que si on choisit de
prendre sur la casse ces six avec les
dixie d'ivoire reprenne sur du foso de
la dame et le plancher 3 n'est plus
attaqué un chien tout simplement une
année noire choisissent quand même mais
d'attaqués d'essayer d'attaquer le roi
des requêtes en prenant le pion h 3o
juin essayant de supprimer le défenseur
du roi et essayer de faire des menaces
voilées les noix en fait et c'est de
pêcher un peu en eaux troubles mais
c'est un bon coup franc un choix est là
cyril donc choisit maintenant de prendre
le cavalier sur la case et 6 à l'air
aussi d'autres bons coups en fait syrie
a vu plus loin oui je ne sais pas moi
j'ai une petite une petite gêne et
interrogations j'ai une petite idée donc
je dévoilerai pas tout de suite parce
qu'il faut attendre le coup de sirène
alors donc là on l'a on et nicolas dans
une variante on est dans un foisonnement
de tactique là c'est à dire que là il
faut vraiment avoir tout calculé parce
qu'il ya beaucoup des changes
il faudra la faire avoir su jugé la
position finale pour savoir qui qui
al'avantage au final absolument alors
les pièces blanches sont plus d'action
que les pièces noires on voit que sont
mieux mobiliser donc les blancs dans
cette position complexe ont plus de
possibilités que les noirs pour faire
des menaces et je crois que le facteur
du roi blanc moins bien protégée
désormais par rapport
on est moins important sans doute que
l'activité des pièces blanches la
colonne de la tour mahler plein de la
promesse à la colonne de la tour sur
laurent adverse
le cavalier blanc peut sauter en plein
centre éventuellement pour soutenir le
pion avancé sur la caste des 500
cavaliers pourraient contrôler des cases
noires proche du roi adverse
je crois que presque toutes les pièces
blanches hormis la tour à gauche à 1
sont en jeu alors que pour les noirs
c'est moins le cas parce que
je trouve que la dame noire est moins
bien placé que la dame blanche pour
faire des menaces mais il ya encore rien
d'évident il faut que les lignes de jeu
forcé soit bonne pour un conte pour
l'autre pour se faire une opinion
exact alors voyons maintenant donc les
noirs choisissent d'abord avant de
reprendre ce fou de faire un échec
en reprenant en faisant un échange de
fou finalement non juste une précision
j'aime beaucoup aimé le commentaire de
nicolas parce que sa kippa l'activié des
pièces et fou prend j'ai deux très
mauvais coup parce que il élimine une
bonne pièce et c'est là que les moments
critiques donc à monde donc j'espère que
ça va pouvoir répondre finalement la
prochaine fois qu'il viendra parce que
j'ai la question de l'autorisation de
les déposer
oui je pense que vous projetez de n'est
pas un bon coup mais j'aimerais en fait
j'aimerais qu'on revienne à un petit peu
la partie pour montrer pourquoi vous
pranger donnait pas un bon coup on
valoir
on va regarder le thème de la partie
mais on se rend le cirad se rappeler que
[ __ ] on fait des mauvais coups et on
verra pourquoi donc la ciel reprendre du
roi voilà et maintenant mon élément
évidemment reprennent la pièce qui était
présent et fils donc égalité matérielle
pour l'instant oui et la syrie le var
seulement 21e coujoux un coup à priori
un peu surprenant il prend finalement le
fou et fils avec sa tour alors qu'on ses
contours
a priori les plus fortes comme fou mais
nancy de vente du matériel finalement
c'est le bon coup mais le seul coup
aussi finalement parce que les noirs
commencé à voir des pièces bien placé le
fouet f6 était bien placé la tour en 1 8
comment savoir une action sur 4 donc
tout point m6 c'est un bon coup c'est le
seul coup pour essayer de nom ce faux en
fait de venir
devenez très gênant et aider les noirs
dans leur défense
donc il fallait l'emmener il faut dire
que ce coup fragilisé terriblement le
roi noir gestion et puis les blancs vont
jouer pour mettre en valeur leurs
monstres qui va apparaître sur la case
dessins que lecavalier se camani qu'il
est rétabli complètement dominateurs il
va y avoir la colonne h aussi mais
maintenant et donc je t'aime prends à 5
tours h1 et il va y avoir donc ex quand
on voit la tour à 8 en haut à gauche on
peut se dire que le cavaly est aussi
fort sinon plus forte que cette tour
parce que quand c'est un sacrifice qui à
court terme mais pas risquer du tout si
les pièces venait trop passé changé
notamment les dames alors ce serait un
gros risque d'avoir sacrifié la qualité
mais les derniers sont encore là pour
longtemps je pense alors on va voir
donc les noirs évidemment reprennent et
qu'on utilisait nicolas leroy noir
maintenant est très affaibli puisque il
a enlevé un grand champion qu'il
défendrait devant donc effective de
recevoir des d échec justement et les
blancs maintenant pour en profiter tout
simplement d'abord ils prennent ce
fameux tueur aux cinq qui traînait
depuis un moment alors cela qui est que
je reviens en arrière
si on remet finalement virtuellement
parce que c'est difficile on remet
virtuellement le roi en h1 si on remet
alors là mais en un chien tout à l'heure
à revoir le juge avant des changes des
fous le fou en h 3 wii et le fou en g2
et bien maintenant les noirs ou le coup
spectaculaire roi g7
on comprend en jeu 7 qui fait venir tout
de suite la tour en h vite et posent des
problèmes aux blancs et peut-être que
les blancs sont perdus moi j'ai analysé
cette position quoi danser sont pas
perdues je pense qu'elle est noire sans
jouer on pourrait prendre le fou oui
mais les tours à tous acheminés à huy
pour agir madame oui nantua chez la dame
c'est quand même là serait très faible
très faible voilà donc voilà une
solution sur l' attaque qui ont été
possibles pour les noirs ne pas échanger
justement donc comme j'aurais dit j'aime
beaucoup de commentaires décoller parce
que les pièces ont comme une valeur
c'est à la fois jeu 3 était beaucoup
plus fort que le fou j'ai deux c'était
une pièce active
il ne fallait pas les changer en plus ce
roi est en achat a été fragilisée alors
là faut être champion du portugal pour
pouvoir ça non mais je pense que juste
sur la valeur des pièces on se rend
compte que tout projet de n'est pas un
bon coup donc on peut on peut être donc
au vu de cette variante maintenant les
blancs ont des possibilités d'attac avec
la dame comme charleroi plus la tour ici
voilà qui peut en un coup participé à
l'attaqué en se mettant sur cette case
il faut dire que vu de cette variante on
peut dire que dans les chansons
on aurait dû garder une pièce finalement
défensive se fout ce fourrage trois
auraient été en fait une pièce qui
aurait gêné attaque
oui oui je pense que maintenant
effectivement la colonnade ouverte pour
la tour blanche la saison va avoir un
effet décisif mais bien sûr donc essayer
de la chance finalement un peu mais il
en faut des phisheurs disais qu'est
champions seuls des champions de la
chance alors on va voir on va voir les
talents les noirs donc essayé de se
défendre maintenant de défendre un peu
le roi en ramenant la tour ici ils
attaquent la dame blanche
beaucoup de défenses et ils peuvent
ramener éventuellement la tour sur une
place défensive son client choisisse de
mettre la dame en h4
ils attaquent alors ils continuent de
menacer cette tour devenir un machin de
faire un échec mortels ici puisque ce
serait un match et aussi ils attaquent
le jura fils pourquoi est-ce qu'il n'a
pas vu le salaire plutôt en h6 salle
aurait pu il aurait pu aussi c'est vrai
qu'après d'héroïne
non je vois tu es noir aurait pu mettre
leur talent même dans la case et fuites
et proposé un échange alors que là la
dame blanche et se soustraient aux
échanges possibles comme ceux comme s'il
était nicolas - ya deux pièces plus
c'est facile pour la défense en défense
il faut noter aussi que le coût de tour
des noirs là il est destiné à prendre le
cavalier sans compter le matériel
lecavalier sera tellement fort que
immédiatement j'imagine la tour noire ou
s'ils se sacrifièrent est aussi
peut-être pour faire une contre attaque
sur l'option g3 masquer le prochain coup
je vois que ces tours j'ai cinq noms il
semblerait que alors on va voir caler
quelle est donc la suite avec donc pour
les noirs le coup tour je fais à manger
sain qui protège un peu le renoir qui
est 6ème peu de mettre une pièce de
vincent roy pour éviter des échecs
désagréable et puis metz peut être par
exemple de jouer aux dames g4 pour
échanger les dames et de faire un petit
aller faire une petite menace sur g31 un
set d'avancé 8 pourrait effectivement
venez sur la musique a échangé contre je
te contredire la menace de mort
qu'est ce qui se passe alors voyons
voilà ce que sur la manade nomades voilà
cyril choisi de mettre sa tour sur la
case h1 et menacent tout simplement
maintenant dame à schwyz
échec et mat donc on l'a on voit la
batterie des pièces lourdes et qui n'a
pas pu être possible s'il n'avait pas
échangé le si on est prêt à échanger une
fois je crois serait peut-être pas été
possible et on voit aussi pourquoi ce
fameux pions qu'on disait qu'il aurait
été mieux h tête au début plutôt que
d'essayer de monter une attaque c'est
que maintenant il manque cruellement des
pions pour défendre le roi peut imaginer
que si les pions avait été encore très
bien le poster comment dit on savait si
ma grand-mère faisait du vélo
alors voyons donc maintenant les noirs
dans sont obligés de jouer un coup de
fuite
finalement c'est un coup de fuite le
couvent revoir complètement force et il
n'y avait pas d'autre façon de pareilles
matt valable tout à cyril a tout vu il
fait un échec
sauf que l'adversaire ce mal répondu à
marche vers ce est donc là les noirs on
on croit qu'on possibilité soit de
mètres la tour c'est le meilleur coach
le plus le plus défensif
amina tour il est blanc aurait pu
prendre peut-être même aussi glissade
amusé 4 et jeu contre attaque se
replonger trois dames g4me la tour sont
réunis faire un nom des échecs des deux
tours j'ai vite c'est parfait sinon
c'est pas facile encore jeune en touche
je sais tu étais vraiment le meilleur
coût parce que bon ça part en même temps
ça laisse un peu de contre jeu pour les
noirs mais le club tricot qui fait c'est
quoi ton père du procès donc à l'attaqué
est très forte le roi noir doit de
répondre à des échecs alors que le roi
de l'homme on est pas encore on est très
sûr il est très sûr mais il est bien
protégé donc les noirs choisissent de
mettre le roi sur la casse le mythe et
sauve à cazaux cette somme plus sûr
aussi bien sur la grille la tour nord
oui mais ensuite mes moyens je vais
perdre suit la position serait perdu
grâce aux pions c6 qui est très avancé
mais là il faut ajouter au g7 parce que
maintenant sur le coup suivant donc le
document neverland un problème six
attaques à tour j'ai cinq ans qu'on perd
un temps finalement plus voilà certes on
est attaqué on a ce matin la deuxième
tour devenir un match il faut de
fonctionnement pied noir par exemple
être là tout ranger vite exactement pour
protéger le mat est requis il a un peu
craqué sous la pression disons mais non
c'est un peu logique puisque c'est c'est
la pression blanche est tellement forte
alors les noirs jouent le trou logique
touche et vite et peut naître d'heure
ils pouvaient jouer d'alger 4 quand même
non vous pouvez alors nicolas propose le
ku'damm ce pour les noirs sur la case g4
maintenant peut-être kibia tourache huit
échecs
maintenant les blancs auraient fait
échec avec amour et touré couvercle à
tout recours protégé par la dame j'ai
quatre tours prend chez huit tours
pranger vite avec échec
willem pranger 8 et 15,8 et finalement
le cavalier à la rescousse menace mat
sur la case ossètes et aussi une
fourchette seront pratiquement par adam
eshet si je voudrais mais fluide pour
paris m en a sept caves et de ses sept
matches
abaisser cette note quand même c'est le
couple d'amis cavaliers sont très très
forts sont supérieures couple dame est
fou par exemple donc il s'agit bien et
contrôle des cases et contre toutes les
cases ensemble les contrôles des cases
diverses et c'est vraiment très fort
mais kelly c'est donc luc adam g quart
temps nicolas est perdant absolument oui
alors les noirs choisissent quand même
de jouer le coup le ton génie tu es là
comme dit jean pierre mercier
donc ça en brique dans libération
nicolas les blancs blancs juillet jouer
son match et jouer et formate exactement
la version c'est d'abord j'avais trop
mal
ils jouent tour à suit exactement tout à
fait cyril a vu d'abord le coup enfin
cesser la même variante est en fait
d'abord le coup quand l'un des cinq
effectivement pour forcer le dieu des
pièces qui force les noirs de protéger
vis surtout sa menace maths et ça
empêche le roi mort de sortir sur le
canot cette force d'âme des jeux sur
sept des huit soldats donc sa forte
houle et noir le ku'damm en des 8es le
joli coup nicolas et orageux suite comme
la tour je suis doué est maintenant
effective entourage suite et si les
noirs prennent la dame tout simplement
on prend d'abord la tour avec échec et
mat
le quart arrière des saints comme
pêcheur le roi noir de sortir et le
fameux pioncer 6 tout à l'heure qui
protège la case 17
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir des pièces qui
contrôlent des cases proche du camp
ennemi
mais je pense que c'était fini les
continuer un petit peu chaque matin ils
annoncent et les villageois
bref non non il a hissé les corps des
trois fuites qui auraient tardé le mat
deux coups weepu joue touré fuite aussi
deux autres pareils tous points fis 3
profite d'abord ils sont rois f8
fectivement qui prouve qu'ils et protège
la tour tout simplement damage six
échecs leroy revient est obligé de
revenir et tout reprendre tour matt donc
là où à leur tour et fuite les noirs à
vendre une tour pointent tous réfutent
tout reprend 1,8 et pour tous à 8 tours
points fis trois premières fuites
damache wittmann
c'est cédric de composition c'est donc
on peut résumer que en fin de cycle
personnel profiter plus des erreurs sur
l'adversaire en fait
sur cette partie bah disons non il a
risqué je pense qu'il aurait un moment
du jeu plus dynamique et prendre un bon
avantage et il a joué un petit peu ces
deux jeux prophylactique dame eu de rush
a essayé de préparer mais bon les noirs
ont très bien répondu ont très bien
défendu et après ils ont il est blond
était un petit peu chanceux en tout cas
un joli tableau de vàd final est très
jeune une torture une exposition à l'or
d'ailleurs comme on peut en trouver dans
le nouveau alors pourquoi j'en parle
nicolas on va on va y revenir mais
pourquoi pourquoi je vais en parler
c'est parce que les bonnes librairies
notamment à paris c'est
une variante est aussi une famille de
l'opéra il ya deux grandes librairies
spécialisées dans les échecs mais voilà
et notament inopérant a rencontré le
directeur de l'opéra au jardin du
luxembourg donc encore une fois la
numération quand je dis y aller tout le
monde
senna nous retrouvons vraiment tout le
monde puisque à part les joueurs
d'échecs les personnalités nous
retrouvons les gens qui font le dessous
de la scène et chicken avec didier
chevalier donc qui qui est le chef et
patron et propriétaire du damier l'opéra
bonjour didier bonjour et loire est ce
que tu peux présenter rapidement ton
activité et le pourquoi es tu venu ici
en gros bas nous sommes venus ici en
tant qu'invité d'opéra à l'inauguration
des jeux que vous avez vu chaque jeu et
fx et donc on a été invité par le
président du sénat lors d'un déjeuner
ensuite d'une inauguration à laquelle
tout le monde participe maintenant c'est
très convivial et ça et j'espère que ça
participera au développement du jeu
d'échecs d'accord et donc ta spécialité
c'est le david l'opéra comme tout le
monde le sait c'est un magasin
spécialisé dans le jeu d'échec on existe
maintenant depuis 25 ans et on a tout ce
qu'il faut pour le joueur d'échecs
échiquier livres et ses logiciels et tu
n'es pas sans savoir que ça peut être
utile tout à fait donc complet
technologique ledemé l'opéra merci merci
dans les jardins du sénat avec le diu
organisateurs de cette manifestation
bertrand guyard bonjour bonjour donc toi
c'est plutôt le côté passion c'est la
passion ça fait des années que je joue
ici dans les jardins du luxembourg dans
le jardin du sénat aux échecs et ça fait
des années que j'attrape des scolioses
ça fait des années que je veux je me
disais ça serait bien qu'on est très
beau jeu l'échec et jean n'en parlait on
en parlais avec mon ami yves marek et un
jour il a été nommé
conseiller du président du sénat et ce
rêve est devenu réalité grâce à lui mais
je crois que c'est la meilleure chose à
faire c'est peut-être lui demandait de
savoir comment il a réussi à convaincre
monsieur ponctuelles président du sénat
de mettre des échiquiers ici donc
monsieur yves marek vous êtes voilà donc
donc on a vu monsieur chevaldonné donc
ces choses là les chevaliers pardon mais
je vais donner c'est le nombre d'échecs
ce chevalier directeur de tam et l'opéra
et donc bertrand guyard qui organise et
qui a organisé avec yves marek du sénat
donc 7,7
cet événement une gestation de
manifestations voilà on va retrouver
maintenant donc le vis donc le
vice-champion de france david massif
marciano enfants la vue est vraiment
nicolas beaucoup de monde cela redonne 3
et manquait seulement spastique j'aurais
aimé revoir ses plans tant que j'avais
pas vu il était invité il est prévenu
il manquait aussi fabrice luchini
l'acteur lui qui est si volubile
ouais tu donnes à venir aussi qui aurait
très bien parlé sans doute du jeu
d'échecs s'il joue comme on l'a vite et
je pense qu'il doit y jouer mais il y
avait des personnalités intéressantes
notamment le metteur en scène jean
becker qui a l'air d'être un bon joueur
d'échecs
quand on a vu une interview à der nière
d'ailleurs comment s'appelle tige
bertrand guyard m'a dit qu'il allait à
peu près mille huit cents lots y avait
jose joe daniels l'avait josé giovanni
qu'à leur catégorie en dessous il y
avait chez vainement à qui et on voit
qu'ils jouent pas souvent ils adorent
ils adorent notables ont été présents
mais si on regarde les coups qu'il a
effectuée c'était un peu ridicule mais
il était plus fort que ça jean becker
parce que avant avant cette
manifestation il y avait fait deux
parties l'une contre etienne bacrot
simultanée et tiennent à venise était
pas encore positif canton jean becker
bon c'est fait aujourd'hui il est
heureux d'autres signent un risque de
passer d'un réalisateur qui sont bons en
échec et aux tâches aussi à winneway ce
stage qui cale à 2100 qui est donc les
gens du cinéma une mise en échec on
dirait oui oui oui oui vous allez voir
aussi des sciences enfin bon pour tout
le monde on va retrouver les terrains
david marciano pour l'interview non non
la part donc donc on leur jette pas le
passé on a passera donc une autre fois
donc le championnat du monde des juniors
donc s'est terminée sur la victoire du
russe ou galkin donc on pour soigner un
peu on peut signaler moi ce que je
voulais dire j'en ai parlé au début ce
c'est que ces chapelles à d'une injure
c'est très important donc voilà parce
que tous les champions du monde toutes
catégories ont été mais ont dû commencer
le vivier c'est la vision champions
c'est là qu'on trouve effectivement les
futurs champions du monde mais comme
actuellement les championnats du monde
sait pas trop ce que ça va soutenir les
pauvres j'ai peur qu'ils qui puisse pas
continuer brillamment leur carrière à ce
propos on a vu la réapparition de qualif
man à noter aussi dans l'actualité qui a
joué pour son équipe de saint
pétersbourg et qui a permis pour le
pétersbourg oui en coupe d'europe de se
qualifier pour la phase finale et
khalife man a fait deux parties nul
contre des joueurs une moyenne de 2550
pour un champion du monde en a tant
mieux mais on a pu quand même mesuré le
la qualité de cali fans et à doter dans
l'actualité aussi stéphane qui va y
avoir bientôt les transferts de joueurs
en nationale 1 qui vont être connu on
imagine qu'il va y avoir un
bouleversement parce qu'il ya une
nouvelle loi sur le nombre de joueurs
étrangers par équipe qui a été modifié
et ça ça fait grincer quelques dents il
ya eu plusieurs présidents de clubs qui
n'étaient pas d'accord avec cette mesure
disons que c'était du protectionnisme
avec l'arrêt bosman on n'avait pas été
vraiment légal c'est les régions le
poser parce que mais il se trouve qu'en
fait beaucoup de fédérations qui
reviennent sur cet arrêt bosman et au
football notamment l'espagne l'italie
qui se demandent s'il faut parvenir un
système de limitation pour favoriser les
jeunes du cru
on verra en tout cas quand on râle
informations finale ce qu'on peut dire
encore une fois c'est que donc champion
du monde je n'aurais se termine et je
crois que les championnats du monde dans
deux catégories donc moins de 16 ans de
14 à 18 ans ont démarré
où ont démarré en espagne je sais que
c'est plus exactement et je sais qu'il
ya laurent frayssinet très grand espoir
également voilà qu'on a vue à besançon
éliminer presque bacrot oui en match de
barrage avant les demi-finales j'étais
là et ça s'est terminé à la sixième
partie de départage que fut beaucoup de
progrès et cette fois ci les redoutables
bon donc voilà donc je vous donne
rendez-vous mais une prochaine fois
nicolas giffard donc saluer quand je
suis ravi de venir à chaque fois où on
est ravi de telle manière donc la
semaine prochaine
josé toutes lettres option à présent ce
jour-là et roddick la semaine prochaine
donc sur diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs merci